-We will help you carve out
the most problematic areas
and what we can do with them
because I think
a common misconception
around death cleaning
is that we're just here to like
throw things out and declutter
and like we're done with it.
But that's not what
it's about. At its heart,
it's about discovering
what's important to you.
-Yeah.
-And what are your hopes
for these things?
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Amy Poehler,
everybody.
That was a clip from "The Gentle
Art of Swedish Death Cleaning."
"The Gentle Art of Swedish
Death Cleaning."
Not a show when I met you
almost two decades ago
I would have thought
would be a show you'd produce.
-Yeah, well, I'm always
growing and changing and...
But it's so cool.
It's based off of a book,
and it is this idea of kind of
kind of how do you want to go
through your things?
How do you want
to live your life?
What conversations
do you want to have
while you're still around
and what stuff
can you get rid of
to not burden the people
who are left when you're gone?
So I do the voice-over for it.
We produced it along with Scout,
the great producers
who do "Queer Eye."
We have three great
Swedish death cleaners
who come in
and are like incredibly
Swedish in the best --
in the best way.
I mean that because
they're so direct.
-Yes.
-And I think clarity is
kindness.
I like direct people.
-Yep.
-As you can probably tell.
And so they just say very --
They get to the point.
-They're almost the opposite
of magicians.
-Uh, 100%.
[ Laughter ]
Magicians are like,
"I'm over here, I'm over there."
And you're like,
"No, you're going to jail.
You're in jail. That's where
you should be -- in jail."
-So your brother, married
to a wonderful Swedish woman,
has a Swedish family,
lives in Sweden.
So you've become very --
you've become very aware
of the beautiful benefits
of the Swedes.
-And you would think
I could speak more Swedish,
but I can't.
But I love that country.
And my brother lives there
with his family and yeah,
and the Swedes have this way of
just saying like,
"This is ugly."
[ Laughter ]
"You don't like it and we don't
like it
and you need to go --
it needs to go away."
And you're just like, "Wow."
[ Laughter ]
They say it really fast
and I like that about them.
-And do you find having, like,
engaged with this,
do you find you're good
at that now in your life?
Are you getting rid of things?
Are there things
that you're keeping
because you want to be able
to pass them on?
-Yeah, I think, right?
Everybody's trying to figure out
what they should keep
for their kids,
what their kids will like,
especially we have kids,
and you think about what their
first apartment,
if they would like
this old rotary phone.
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "How many DVDs
are they going to be into?"
-They might come back.
I feel as though by the time
your kids go to college.
-Well, not --
I do feel, though,
that A.I. is going to kill us.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-And I, you know,
we're Gen X,
so I think we are
the last generation
that are not going
to mate with robots.
[ Laughter ]
I think we will
fight against the robots.
But Gen Z will love
and marry robots.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
And that will be hard
because we will be obviously
waging some sort of sort
of underground revolution
against the robots
and at the same time,
your sons are going
to bring them home.
-Exactly, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then you're
going to have to act
like you like the robot.
-Exactly. You're going to
have to make the choice.
Like, do I save
my half robot, half human son?
-Yeah.
-Or do I kill him because I know
he's going to put
worms in my brain
or whatever they're going to do?
I can't even imagine
what -- I'm no robot.
I'm a human.
[ Laughter ]
But I don't like it.
and I won't date a robot.
-You won't?
-No.
-Interesting. Even if --
-Nope. No matter how hard
you try.
-Can I try to sell you on it?
Alright.
-You're not going to sell me
on it. I'm not dating a robot.
-Okay, but here's the thing.
Here's how the A.I. love robot
that we're developing works.
At first it's going
to be bad, right?
It's not going to work out.
But each successive date,
the A.I. will learn
more about you.
And then -- so by like date 10,
you'll be like,
"Oh, we really understand."
You have to feed the A.I. robot.
-Oh, I have to feed it?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, great. So it's like
a human man, then?
Is that what you're
talking about?
[ Laughter ]
I have to tell it what I like
and then it knows?
-Yeah.
Also, you got to plug it in. You
got to remember to plug it in.
-I have to return every couple
of years --
I'm like, "It's broken.
I need a new --"
It's like the iPhone.
I'm like, "I need
a new robot boyfriend."
No, I won't date a robot
no matter how hard you try.
Unless...
-Okay.
-He picks up food
on the way home.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. That's the one thing?
I feel like robots
almost already do that.
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
Those robots that, like, go --
Have you seen them
on the street?
Well, you guys probably
don't care
because you're all Gen Z,
and you're like,
"That's cute."
-Yeah.
-It's not going to be cute
when you go home
and you lift up your covers
and it's living there
and it's going to kill you
and strangle you.
-Do you feel like --
Are you overwhelmed
by the technology
your kids are engaging with?
-Yeah. Although, you know,
have you tried that chat --
Maybe you guys have done bits
on it here about ChatGPT.
-Yeah, no, we haven't really
messed around with it much.
-You haven't messed
around with it?
-No.
-Okay. So it can't
really write a joke yet.
I don't think. And once it
writes a joke, like game's over.
-Yeah. No, that's actually --
-That's it.
-We're just going to do
one real sad last show.
-Yeah.
-There's going to be
a robot dressed
just like me
sitting there waiting.
-Yeah.
-Like [Whirring]
-And then it's just like, yeah,
it can't write comedy yet,
but, I mean, I'm sure
it will in like a week.
-Yeah. This is like --
You know what?
It's so great that you're here
on our last week.
[ Laughter ]
-Our last human week.
-Oh, man.
What a great thing to have you
here on our last human week.
You were here
on our first human week,
and you were here on our last.
-I know you're --
When is your anniversary
for your 10 years?
Next year?
-Next February is 10 years.
-Wow. That's awesome.
-Isn't that crazy?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I always say it.
I mean, I got to give credit
where credit is due
because our first show,
you were first.
It was very important to me
that you were our first guest.
And then that meant we
had to ask the second guest,
who was a young fellow named
Vice President Joe Biden.
[ Laughter ]
Now, usually vice presidents,
when they're on a 12:30 show,
would go first.
-Yes.
-And we did say to Joe Biden,
"Would you be okay following
Amy Poehler?"
And to his credit, he was like,
"I'll follow her anywhere."
So very, very charming,
very sweet of him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, it's lovely
to have you here, as always.
How about break a leg, wherever
you may bring your legs?
I'm very excited for
the Restless Leg tour.
I think we're all very excited.
-Thank you very much, Seth.
I really appreciate it.
And I love coming here.
You know I love you.
Thank you so much.
I love you. Goodbye.
-Pick up the check.
Pick up the check.
Amy Poehler, everybody.